panneau lumineux géant pin's pétition à
l'entrée le ton est donné les yvelines
et les hauts-de-seine refuse la future
métropole et l'ont fait savoir ce mardi
soir lors de leur cérémonie de voeux
commune
ce redécoupage étudié par l'état vise à
créer une métropole de rang mondial
limité à paris à la petite couronne
exit les autres départements de la
région parisienne dont les yvelines
on nous parle de simplification mais
c'est pour inventer à chaque fois de
nouvelles usines à gaz qui nous
contraignent à des dépenses d'énergie et
d'argent considérables sans jamais
produire le moindre bénéfice mesurable
il mesure qui mettra en péril la fusion
entre les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine
à rapprochement opéré depuis 2016 vous
avez une voiture qui est en panne et une
voiture qui marche
vous prenez pas la voiture qui marche
pour réparer la voiture qui est en panne
c'est ce qui est en train de faire le
gouvernement et ça ça m'agace parce que
c'est dramatique
ça nous mettra tous à pied là où il
faudrait qu'on monte dans une voiture
qui est celle de la croissance dans leur
sillage les présidents des cinq autres
départements d'île de france ont pris la
parole au pupitre ou via des vidéos pour
dénoncer ce futur redécoupage le
socialiste le communiste l'homme de
droite
tous ces gens sont ensemble sont
d'accord il faut décentraliser parce que
un service public qui fonctionne c'est
un service qui est à proximité des
besoins des usagers pour la république
en marche le scénario n'est pas encore
tranchée l'elysée devrait communiquer
dans les prochaines semaines sur le
nouveau statut de cette métropole
tout dépend des compétences qui seront
affectés aussi aux différentes entités
je pense en tout cas ce qui est attendu
c'est plus d'efficacité et plus de
simplicité parce qu'aujourd'hui nos
concitoyens et savent pas forcément
qu'elle est l'entité pertinente pour
quelles actions à mener pour apaiser les
tensions la soirée s'est clôturée par
des concerts de musique classique la
chanson devrait être différent dans les
prochains jours sur la scène politique
régionale le 31 janvier les sept
présidents de départements se
rassembleront de nouveau à boulogne
billancourt pour défendre une métropole
régionale